[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue c'est un plaisir de vous
retrouver pour notre débat quotidien
entre de fin observateur de la vie
contemporaine bonsoir jérôme sainte
marie
vous êtes politologues sondeurs vous
avez fondé la société pôle inbox vous
est aussi l'auteur de bloc contre bloc
la dynamique du maquereau nisme qui a
été publié aux éditions du cerf bonsoir
mathieu sougueur vous êtes consultant
expert associé à la fondation jean
jaurès et vous avez collaboré entre
autres avec la ministre socialiste du
travail myriam el khomri on commence par
parler si vous le voulez bien de ce
projet de loi qui est enfin arrivée au
conseil des ministres aujourd'hui projet
de loi contre les séparatistes mal
adapté de plus appelé comme ça on y perd
un peu son vocabulaire mais en tout cas
l'idée c'est de lutter contre des
dérives essentiellement islamistes qui
viendrait à séparer de la communauté
nationale
un certain nombre de groupes derrière ce
projet de loi il y a les tenants de la
laïcité les militants peut-être même
ceux ci sont parfois critiqués on leur
dit qu'ils sont des laïcards qu'ils
auraient l'obsession des musulmans qu'il
ferait l'amalgamé entre l'islam et
l'islam ils ont sait on va en parler
pour savoir quel est votre avis sur ce
sujet mais je vous propose d'abord de
voir une réaction assez intéressante et
peut être surprenante puisque elle nous
vient des états unis
c'est celle de sam brownback raza brawn
d'accès l'ambassadeur des états unis
pour la liberté religieuse est un poste
qui n'existe pas chez nous et celui ci
dit je suis inquiet pour ce qui se passe
en france quand on est trop répressif la
situation peut s'aggraver
le rôle du gouvernement c'est de
protéger la liberté religieuse
et puis toujours dans les critiques de
l'esprit de cette loi qui confondraient
peut-être la lutte contre l'islamisme
avec celle contre l'islam on va en
parler dans un instant il ya ce tweet
d'un avocat qui s'appelle arié alimi
c'est l'un des dirigeants de
la ligue des droits de l'homme et lui le
renvoi carrément dose ados laïciste et
islamistes combattons les extrémistes
sans faillir dit-il alors maintenant on
va donner la parole à la défense
à marlène schiappa qui au ministère de
l'intérieur est l'un des responsables
gouvernementaux qui porte ce projet de
loi elle n'apprécie pas du tout qu'on
met sur le même plan les laïcistes et
les islamistes si choqué par certains
qui renvoie dos-à-dos islamistes et
laïciste personne n'a jamais tué
quelqu'un au nom de la laïcité donc des
gens qui sont très fortement pour la
laïcité ce sont des gens qui sont très
fortement pour la liberté de conscience
qu'ils sont très fortement pour la
liberté de culte qui sont très fortement
pour lutter contre l'endoctrinement et
contre l'emprise et les dérives
sectaires des gens qui sont très
fortement pour la liberté pour l'égalité
pour la fraternité
je ne crois pas que ce soit condamnable
et je ne crois pas qu'il soit opportun
de les renvoyer dos à dos avec des
islamistes qui tue alors nous avons
appelé notre débat les laïcards avec
toutes les guillemets qui s'impose en
font-ils trop et si nous avons choisi ce
nom bien c'est parce que il est repris
comme titre d'un article du monde à la
fois descriptif est un peu critique
contre cette tendance de la laïcité
dirons-nous offensive et alors dans cet
article on lit que les laïcards ce sont
ces soldats de l'ombre qui oeuvrent dans
les cabines hysteria elle mais aussi
dans les institutions telles que la
fondation jean jaurès think tank de
gauche dont les publications aide à
peser sur les décisions alors mathieu
soupière êtes vous un soldat de l'ombre
qui ont vocation à produire de
l'expertisé de temps en temps produits
et expertises qui sert aux décideurs
attendus dans le vôtre ça en boxant on
ne peut que s'en réjouir les en tout cas
tous les commentaires qu'on vient de
convient d'entendre et y compris
l'article du monde que vous venez de
citer ont un mérite
il illustre en fait le fait que la
république est censé nous fédérer est
censé nous rassemble est invoqué la
république est censée nourrir une forme
de cohésion entre nous tous la laïcité
et tente un des piliers de cette
république la laïcité devrait là aussi
en fait nous mettre tous d'accord
et nous révèle qu'à et nourrir une forme
de concorde est en fait la laïcité
aujourd'hui crée de la cré de la
division c'est d'autant plus farfelues
pardon pour le terme mais la laïcité
tout le monde en fait tout le monde est
d'accord la laïcité tout le monde la
reconnaît à part quelques quelques
quelques marginaux mais vraiment à la
marge les témoins n'ont pas la même
ambition
non non mais met tout le monde d accord
y compris pardon mais les musulmans en
fait quand vous faites des enquêtes
d'opinion sur la loi de 1905 et la
laïcité
tout le monde adhère à ce principe
fondateur personne ne le remet en cause
ensuite vous avez raison effectivement
guillaume il peut y avoir des
appréciations un peu un peu différente
de ce qu'est la laïcité et au delà même
des différences d'appréciation
il ya une forme de là encore d'ironie de
l'histoire ceux qui se sont longtemps
opposés à la laïcité je pense notamment
à l'extrême droite qui encore une fois
dans son terreau idéologique a combattu
et historiquement a combattu la laïcité
aujourd'hui avec marine le pen est la
première devant toutes les toutes les
caméras et face à tous les micros à se
faire
l'ardent défenseur d'une laïcité elle en
serait menacée la question c'est est ce
que c'est c'est militant de la laïcité
est ce qu'ils en font trop
alors rencontre l'islam soyons clairs ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'ils en font assez
en tout cas pour avoir imposé cette
question de l'islam est globalement même
la question identitaire au coeur de
l'agenda politique
pendant très longtemps la gauche et la
droite se sont opposés au tour d'une
dimension essentielle la question
sociale la question sociale a été
globalement évacués au cours des
dernières années est remplacé par la
question identitaire jeu je ne nie pas
l'importance de débattre de ces sujets
la question de l'identité la question de
la nation la question de la frontière
nourri un débat qui n'a rien médiocre
néanmoins je note que aujourd'hui et je
dirais même que la classe politique le
parlement estac consacrent une part
considérable de son énergie de son temps
de cerveau disponible et même de son
temps de débat dans l'hémicycle
à la question de l'islam à la question
de l'islam il ya quatre à cinq millions
de musulmans aujourd'hui dans ce pays
qui dans leur immense majorité ne pose
évidemment aucune difficulté à la
république je dirais même que non
seulement ils ne posent aucun problème
mais en revanche dans leur vie
quotidienne
compte tenu de ce que sont leurs
conditions d'existence bien souvent eux
rencontrent des problèmes il ya quatre
ou cinq étudiants musulmans on en fait
trop et il ya de voir des muscles
que oui il ya deux fois plus de pauvres
alors en fait on trop à partir du moment
où on n'arrive pas à avoir un débat
serein alors même qu encore une fois
tout le monde se reconnaît tout le monde
tombe d'accord sur ce qu'est le socle
des valeurs républicaines
tout le monde tombe d'accord sur ce
qu'est la laïcité on doit pouvoir
supporter des nuances dans le débat
supporter des mieux encore une fois les
uns et les autres s'invectivent en étant
en fait d'accord pourquoi certains à
gauche la gauche la droite et pas
divisés sur la laïcité elle a longtemps
combattu la laïcité aujourd'hui en
réalité elle marche comme un seul homme
ou comme une seule femme
derrière cette bannière qui l'arrangent
peut-être bien peut-être pour des
raisons tactiques
en tout état de cause le débat a surtout
lieu à gauche et est d'ailleurs lé
insulte suprême dans la période
c'est islamo-gauchiste banias pas à
l'islam au droitisme et islamo gauchiste
effectivement c'est une insulte très en
vogue
pourquoi pour une raison très simple la
gauche a toujours été encore une fois
historique pau du côté de la laïcité
elle constate que ses ennemis d'hier
sont venus sur son propre terrain et
elle constate par ailleurs ou en tout
cas elles redoutent que la laïcité soit
évidemment instrumentalisé
instrumentalisée pour stigmatiser une
communauté qui se trouve être déjà
discriminées
au plan social donc voilà pourquoi la
gauche reste extrêmement prudente et
c'est très habile puisque la gauche la
gauche et prudente vous aussi chers
match que ça n'est pas une jugement de
valeur c'est un constat et vous y êtes
mariés ce que vous pourriez y répondre à
cette question est ce que on en fait
trop
dans le camp laïc
contre l'islamisme au risque d'un
amalgame c'est un mot bien connu avec
l'islam non je crois pas du tout tout
simplement que ces querelles sont
tournés querelles violente
marlène schiappa a tort de dire que
personne n'est mort pour la laïcité en
1906 lorsqu'il ya eu les inventaires des
biens religieux
après la loi de 1905 il y a eu des morts
c'est à dire qu'effectivement des gens
était une maman d'une église je crois il
ya eu quelques morts ce n'était pas non
plus un bain de sang mais une quelques
morts parce que les défis d elle
s'opposait sous d'ailleurs comme le
faisait d'ailleurs l'église s'opposer à
ces inventaires
encore une fois c'est très conflictuelle
une espèce de petite légende qui se
répand selon lequel il y aurait la
laïcité procéderait la religion
catholique
ça m'est complètement échappé au pape à
l'époque c'est une autre les mecs c'est
effectivement à l'époque à la fin don du
sang au début de la troisième république
puis ensuite à part en 1905
c'est extrêmement virulent et cette
querelle il faut attendre la libération
en quelque sorte pour qu'elle soit parce
qu'il ya un retour de balancier sous le
général maréchal pétain et avec une
approbation une bonne partie dans ce
domaine là d'une bonne partie de
l'église de france l'a aujourd'hui tout
ça est totalement gommée totalement
ligue et cetera donc c'est normal qu'il
y ait effectivement une relation
conflictuelle des relations
conflictuelles à ce sujet c'est normal
qu'ils aient des formes de
stigmatisation en réalité relisez
l'assiette au beurre ce que l'on pouvait
dire à écrire à l'époque toutes les
caricatures anticlérical
il y avait effectivement une très forte
stigmatisation des catholiques par les
laïcs et puis en sens inverse
très probablement c'était des querelles
terrible absolument terrible et c'est
assez normal sauf que la différence
c'est quoi c'est qu'en fait on est un
pays qui est largement déchristianisée
maintenant il ya moins d'un mois tier
des enfants qui ne sont baptisés ça
s'effondre à une vitesse
il suffit de lire la publication
annuelle fait par les archevêques de
francs les évêques de france est très
intéressant ils ont des statistiques
assez cruel d'ailleurs qui montre
justement cette déchristianisation et
pour ceux qui sont encore chrétiens qui
pratique à tout petit peu etc
eh bien ils ont tendance à s'affranchir
terriblement en réalité des règles qui
étaient autrefois impérative
je pense au carême à ce genre de choses
désormais c'est des choses comme vous
baisser or là on a une religion qui
arrive qui elle n'a pas du tout les
mêmes codes et qui semble à travers le
monde et notamment le monde musulman qui
semble suivre un chemin exactement
inverse avec au contraire toutes les
sociétés des pays musulmans qui sont de
plus en plus astreintes à règle
religieuse va forcément il ya un choc
et forcément il ya une stigmatisation
quand la france a soumis ce dim
derrière laïcité ou stigmatiser l'islam
aujourd'hui oui bien sûr c'est une
évidence mais c'est une évidence logique
c'est pas un problème en soi
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est bien sûr
qu'il ya une forme de deux conflits et
ce conflit je ne vois pas comment on
peut y échapper
je voudrais faire créer une toute petite
remarque pour finir mon propos c'est que
les mots sont particulièrement apprécié
dans cette affaire je suis pas sûr que
la france est un énorme problème de
laïcité assure à la france à des
institutions laïques qui fonctionne qui
traite avec ce qu'il faut de
surveillance et d'indifférence les
différentes religions
l'état n'est pas l'état est laïc il n'y
a pas de problème là dessus
alors évidemment la france insoumise va
nous parler des trois départements régie
par le concordat ou deux et en oubliant
d'ailleurs meilleur tous là c'est par
contre le droit islamique etc
enfin bon tout ça est très marginal
inversement c'est pas le propre de
laïcité qu'on a un problème
d'assimilation c'est un problème
d'assimilation c'est pas au niveau de
l'état que ça se passe
c'est au niveau de la société il ya
effectivement des problèmes
d'assimilation
d'où le terme qui ne paraissait pas
idiot de séparatisme beaucoup de
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux à vos
propos monsieur martin sur youtube qui
nous dit en 1905 les gens ne sont pas
morts pour la laïcité mais pour l'anti
cléricalisme
effectivement c'est de tout et dans les
mots comme vous le disiez très juste
qu'en chair jérôme
cocorico sur lefigaro.fr oui et la
liberté de conscience et de croire non
au prosélytisme
et puis pascal sur youtube qui faisons
bien la distinction entre musulmans et
islamistes
les musulmans sont pacifiques ils n'ont
pas besoin de loi pour s'adapter les
islamistes eux veulent convertir le
monde entier aucune loi ne les fera
s'adapter alors à quoi bon une réaction
intéressante
babineau sur lefigaro.fr s'étonne que le
mot islamisme n'apparaissent pas dans le
projet de loi
le mot séparatisme est très maladroit
estime-t-il il ya eu débat sur ce sujet
et cher babineau et sauf que pont plein
de raisons notamment le danger d'une
forte d'inconstitutionnalité
si une loi a été spécifiquement sur une
religion on l'a pas on ne l'a pas
exprimé ni islam et c'est normal ni
islamisme et ça effectivement ça a pu
faire débat et puis mj sur youtube comme
pour toutes les lois il faut des actes
et pas seulement des paroles en plus de
sa ouvrir les frontières au monde entier
ne fera que contredire cette loi avec
l'immigration illégale
mathus hook rmj nous dit il faut des
actes pas des paroles
ce qui est intéressant dans ce débat
c'est que c'est pas un truc abstrait il
ya des choses très concrètes par exemple
dans le camp laïc
il ya des gens qui disent il faudrait
que les mères voilées ne puisse pas
accompagner les sorties scolaires parce
que l'école doit être un lieu de
neutralité et puis d'autres qui disent
pas du tout c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est pas simplement une
querelle théologique entre guillemets
leur nom c'est il ya quand même un des
accords de principe en l'occurrence si
on voit bien que les gens ont une
acception du la notion de laïcité qui
peut être parfois extensive j'ai quand
même l'impression qu'on s'y perd un peu
si c'est que c'est quand même là une loi
de circonstance et je ne dis pas qu'il
s'agit de communication politique mais
on voit bien qu'un certain nombre de
dispositions qui constituent cette loi
en réalité représente une réalité qui
est à peu prêt marginal
la question de la scolarisation des
enfants par exemple on voit bien que on
n'a pas des dizaines de milliers
d'enfants qui derrière cette affaire
vont être concernés la presse et marlène
schiappa en tête enfin d'ailleurs ne
cesse de parler des certificat de
virginité et c'est bien qu'on ait chose
que
on est sur des choses qui en réalité de
mettre tous d'accord d'accord personne
je pense notre position ambiguë sur ces
sujets là et en même temps encore une
fois on parle d'une réalité qui est
statistiquement à la marge
donc on crée un débat politique on
focalise l'agenda politique autour d'une
loi qui derrière en termes d'action
concrète ne va pas se traduire par mille
choses par mille choses et qui a encore
une fois devrait apporter de la concorde
et me semble créer de la division de la
division dans le pays dans l'opinion et
de la division y compris au sein même de
la classe politique en était tout à
l'heure jérôme faisait le parallèle avec
la fin du 19e siècle début du xxème et
en parlant enfin en justifiant la
conflictuelle it2 de ce sujet alors oui
pour la conf lituanie t à la fin du 19e
siècle ou au début du xxème à l'époque
ou encore une fois la république
s'affranchit du pouvoir de la religion
catholique la religion catholique
à l'époque réel pouvoir et la religion
catholique est par ailleurs la religion
de l'immense majorité de la population
donc on voit bien qu'à l'époque le
conflit et est forcément nourrit
aujourd'hui
non on parle d'une affaire bien
différente la société française comme le
disait jérôme est totalement
déchristianisée mais globalement elles
mêmes en fait libérer de ce qui pourrait
s'apparenter à une forme de deux jours
religieuse idéologie religieuse alors
pas en toute chose on voit bien que par
exemple la religion catholique reste une
religion dominante est importante et qui
a pesé lourd au moment des débats autour
du mariage pour tous on est d'accord
mais mais mais sinon au delà de ça
encore une fois j'y reviens la laïcité
est admise y compris par les musulmans
dans les enquêtes d'opinion
la loi de 1905 les musulmans de la
remettant en cause les autorités
musulmanes tel qu'il existe en descente
à elle ne voyait qu'eux il ya beaucoup
de jeunes musulmans qui disent alors
peut-être que vous considérez que ce
n'est pas incompatible avec la laïcité
mais on en a d ailleurs débattues ici
que les principes de la religion sont
supérieurs à ceux de la république
c'est une vision et je ne dis pas
d'ailleurs qu'il n'y a pas de sujet qui
a pas de problème vous avez raison et y
compris chez les plus jeunes nokia vient
absolument donc il ya un vrai travail la
colocation mais noté où vous l'avez vu
avec le commentaire du de représentants
officiels américains noter que à
l'étranger également la question de la
laïcité questionne et et qu'encore une
fois ce soit est une notion qui soit
vivante
qu'aujourd'hui on n'en débatte et qu'on
fasse même évolué l'appréhension qu'on
accepte cette réalité là ne paraît pas
du tout absurde il ya juste un élément
quand même on est d'accord autour de
deux valeurs
la laïcité est la liberté d'expression
la question est de savoir si cette
laïcité cette liberté d'expression sont
à géométrie variable
je vous donne un héros l'émission
s'appelle point de vue mon point de vue
quand le ministre de l'éducation a parlé
de tenues républicaine de tenues
républicaine d'accord on en la
république qui est une langue morte
parfois comme comme disait un ancien
premier ministre
la république se soucie désormais de
savoir comment s'habille certains je ne
voulais pas de vêtements islamiques
soyons clairs non mais c'était même
c'était fin non non non c'est il
s'agissait pas de vie de batman
ces deux lecteurs n'y aurait qu'une
tenue contre les jets ou trop gras y ait
entre guy menut correct et vous avez
raison c'était pas c'était pas sur
l'essai de quoi la république se mêlent
telle attention attention tout de même
mais de respecter arrivons à conjuguer
quand même une forme de cohésion
collective et de liberté individuelle je
donne le mot de la fin sur ce sujet à
jérôme sainte marie mais pas avant
vous avoir fait part de du résultat la
question du jour c'est sur le site du
figaro la question est le projet de loi
sur les principes républicains
donc ce projet de loi qui est présenté
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres
sera-t-il efficace pour lutter contre
l'islamisme et vous êtes assez dubitatif
puisque ses 84 % qui répondent
négativement leur dire on se pose des
problèmes en france qu'on se pose pas
ailleurs moi je trouve ça normal sauf un
seul identité française c'est vrai que
toute une série de choses dans les pays
anglo saxons il suffit de traverser
d'ailleurs la manche pour voir en grande
bretagne ces questions vestimentaires
on considère aux etats unis c'est encore
plus large on considère grosso modo que
la société composée d'individus régi par
des règles de droit et qu'on est libre
là dessus de s'habiller comme ceux ci
comme cela de l'est et puis si on n'est
pas content on va en prendre on va dans
des écoles comme ceci ou comme cela là
la france s'est construite très
différemment et jusqu'à présent donc
elle est régie par des règles beaucoup
plus sévères et considère qu'elle
constitue une société qui n'est pas une
île simplement un agrégat d'individus
avec uniquement des règles juridiques
qui les relie c'est notre conception
c'est d'ailleurs la mienne aussi et donc
à partir de là si vous voulez la
question est beaucoup plus pour
reprendre à vous savez c'est du grand
débat sur cinq a été malmené sans doute
mais par nicolas sarkozy sur l'identité
nationale en réalité on considère c'est
pour ça que ces mots de république et le
tenue républicaine ne sont utilisés à
tort et à travers
c'est la laïcité a est utilisé aussi de
manière très large alors que encore une
fois pour moi c'est une question
d'assimilation avec des règles de vie on
n'arrive pas tout nu en classe par
exemple au fond pourquoi pas profond
pourquoi pas on n'arrive pas tous les
ans classes ni aux bureaux
il est à remarquer eh bien pourquoi pas
ce serait seulement bon pour l'audience
c'est des règles qui nous sont imposés
mais ils sont imposés par la société se
fait ma mère si et droit c'est juste
rappeler ces règles là juste pour finir
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'il soit
extrêmement précises parce que pour les
étrangers qui arrivent en france qui
deviennent français qui élèvent leurs
enfants pour qu'ils soient français
il faut qu'enfin ils connaissent les
règles qui soit stable et qu'il faut
respecter
merci beaucoup trois points de vue
d'internautes pour terminer ce premier
débat
gérard sur lefigaro.fr qui trouve que
vous avez parfaitement raison jérôme
l'islam n'est pas un problème religieux
mais sociétal la seringue
c'est un pseudonyme probablement d'un
internaute qui nous dit oui les laïcards
en font trop mais certains musulmans
aussi la laïcité ce n'est pas la guerre
de religion avec respect considère au
contraire toujours sur le figaro.fr que
les laïcards n'en font pas trop qu'on
parle tant de la religion 21e siècle
pose question vous avez cité le nom de
nicolas sarkozy
jérôme sainte marie vous savez qu'il ya
actuellement un procès dans lequel il
est impliqué le préféré de l' affaire
dite des écoutes dit aussi la sphère
bismuth
le réquisitoire des deux
procureur-adjoint du parquet national
financier a surpris par sa sévérité
quatre ans de prison dont deux avec
sursis contre l'ancien président de la
république
les deux autres prévenus gilbert azibert
et thierry herzog ont eux aussi fait
l'objet de réquisitions très sévère est
ce qu'on en fait trop et est ce que le
pnf règle des comptes dans une forme de
justice politique écouter d'abord un
point de vue celui de jacqueline laffont
c'est l'avocate du de l'ancien président
de la république je dirais que le parti
a déserté l'accusation et qu'aujourd'hui
il a parlé très fort il a proposé des
peines qui ne sont que des peines
proposées l'a d'ailleurs appelé lui même
ce ne sont que des réquisitions et
encore une fois je n'ai aucun doute nous
démontrons ses réquisitions parce que
encore une fois elles ont été démontées
des chats au cours de l'audience et que
ce sera très facile pour nous de le
faire alors on rappellera comme le
précise et à juste titre m la faune que
ce ne sont que deux réquisitoires donc
c'est le tribunal qui va décider
et ça ce sera probablement après la mise
en délibéré dans quelques semaines
est-ce que c'est trop sévère bah écoutez
il ya un point de vue intéressant celui
de 2
d'un ancien magistrat philippe bilger
qui a lui-même été avocat général de la
cour d'assises de mémoire à la cour
d'appel de paris est lui persuadé qu'il
va y avoir des relaxes il dit relaxe
pour tout le monde ou plutôt trois
relaxes sinon rien point d'exclamation
la question qui se pose mathus au caire
c'est est-ce que ce lot réquisitoire
c'est l'expression d'une forme de
justice politique pour faire court parce
que si ça n'avait pas été un ancien
président de la république le parquet
n'aurait pas été aussi dur le problème
de la justice c'est que qu'elle condamne
là en l'occurrence il ya encore une fois
il s'agit uniquement de réquisitoire pas
du tout de condamnation mais qu'elle
condamne ou qu'elle ne condamne pas dès
lors qu'un politique est mêlé à la fête
dès lors qu'elle a à se soucier du sort
d'un politique elle est immédiatement
suspecté soit en grand une fois de ne
pas condamner et donc et donc d'être aux
ordres soit de condamner et vouloir
faire un une sorte d' abus de pouvoir
donc c'est toujours assez compliqué
alors moi je ne suis pas juriste pas
magistrat pas avocate pas d'avis sur le
la sévérité du réquisitoire
je note juste que même s'il ne s'agit
que d'un réquisitoire sait sauf erreur
de ma part
la première fois qu'un président de la
république ex président de la république
se soit confronté à un réquisitoire
l'exposant un risque de prison ferme
là deux ans de prison ferme ça paraît
totalement délirant je n'en sais rien
mais en tout cas ça questionne alors
d'autant plus que c'est ce que je crée
les dire à la fin personne n'a profité
de rien dans cette affaire et qu'il n'y
a pas de preuves matérielles de la
corruption
non donc je effectivement on tout ça par
un mérite prudemment mais quand même
vous dites c'est rude quoi tout ça
paraît très cher payés oui mais je note
20 le point qu'on peut noter quand même
c'est que c'est la première fois encore
une fois que un ex président de la
république s'expose au risque de deux
ans de prison ferme
j ajoute un deuxième élément concernant
nicolas sarkozy qui entre guillemets
fait désordre
je je je crois aussi sans commettre
d'erreurs qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
présidents ou ex président de la
république qui a été confronté un
faisceau d'autant d'affaires car en
l'occurrence nicolas sarkozy défraie la
chronique de façon régulière et même
récurrente pour un nombre d'affaires
considérable dans une sorte de poupée
russe d'ailleurs où chaque affaire
débouche sur une autre au fur et à
mesure des écuries absolument alors un
sdk blanchi à chaque fois un sou le nook
sur la sphère bygmalion
les choses ont été un peu plus compliqué
pour lui donc je vois là c'est
appartement où nous traversons une crise
démocratique et que cette crise
démocratique s'appuie notamment sur un
niveau de défiance considérable et une
suspicion de corée de corruption
généralisée concernant la classe
politique le fait qu'un ex président de
la république qui est pourtant qui a
pourtant quitté le pouvoir en étant
relativement populaire soit aujourd'hui
face à les tribunaux avec un faisceau
d'affaires diverses
malheureusement pose question sainte
marie justice politique ou pas oui j'ai
donné mon point de vue qui sera assez
précis et assez tranchées et qui sera
très différent nous avons été désolés
enfin j'en suis même content que doivent
être les soupières ça serait quand même
dommage qu'on soit toujours d'accord
l'accident savoir que je considérais que
c'était un pur scandale
ce réquisitoire que la procédure
elle-même pose des problèmes importants
à 3 contre on a le droit vous parle sous
votre contrôle de critiquer non pas une
décision de justice mais réquisitoire ne
sais pas elle voudrait sortir libre ce
studio est par ailleurs sky a dit
matthew key m'inquiète encore davantage
le dossier n'existe pratiquement pas
c'est une affaire de corruption qui ont
voit pas très bien même nicolas sarkozy
n'est pas intervenu ça se passe sur sûr
au départ sur des écoutes qui elle-même
pose un problème terrible écoute de
l'avocat de nicolas sarkozy
donc déjà il ya une démarche de la part
du parquet qui est assez effrayante
sauf erreur c'est le pas le célèbre parc
national financiers dont on a vu les
ouvrages les oeuvres depuis trois ans
avec la mise en examen de françois
fillon pendant la campagne
présidentielle s'il n'y avait pas cette
instance créée par françois hollande le
parquet national financiers mercredi ce
rayman le maquereau par bons ne seront
pas présents la république mais tout le
monde avait salué à l'époque sa créature
bonne voiture pas de loi ne peut pas
tout le monde loin de là par ailleurs
vous avez la classe politique
effectivement vous avez oui mais la
presse politique à la peur que
voulez-vous donc elle a raison d'avoir
peur à faire fillon l'a aussi donc
discrédit en pleine campagne qu'il devra
y aurait-il été blanchi si vous voulez à
la fin que de façon il avait perdu
l'élection à faire le pen à faire
mélenchon tient les trois principales
opposition d'emmanuel macro comme ça
tombe bien et ensuite maintenant nicolas
sarkozy en quoi c'est extrêmement
préoccupant
comme vous l'avez dit on dit mais quand
même ça fait mauvais genre
un présent de la république et contre
lequel on recourt à des peines de prison
pour corruption
si vous connaissez pas le dossier vous
dites il ya pas de fumée sans feu
ça doit être très grave qu'a fait
nicolas sarkozy on parle de corruption
on parle de poursuites pénales rires
c'est terrible or en réalité le dossier
quasiment vide
ça signifie quoi je n'ai pas du tout que
parquet national financier est aux
ordres du pouvoir en place
j'en sais rien peut-être qu'ils oublient
qu'à lui m il serait encore plus grave
d'une certaine manière ça signifie que
nous vivons sous comment dirais-je la
menace constante d'une intrusion dans le
jeu démocratique da parquet qui n'en
fait qu'à sa tête et qui peut
parfaitement fausse et la prochaine
élection présidentielle
comme il a faussé l'élection précédente
évidemment le poids politique dans la
dans le débat public a toujours le
mauvais rôle est par contre les médias
la justice tout ça on toujours le beau
rôle mais c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe
encore une fois ce parquet national
financier peut à tout moment dans et ça
se produira vous le verrez à mon avis
dans l'année qui vient en tout cas d'ici
à l'élection présentielle pronta mais
des poursuites détruire la campagne de x
ou y
et c'est là c'est une véritable c'est
une prise de pouvoir par le juridique
par un parquet qui est une instance
d'exception le parquet national
financier qui d'ailleurs a totalement
échappé à la conception de départ c'est
pas de la sphère financière complexe
dont il s'occupe c'est des problèmes de
six temps parlementaire c'est ce
problème là et donc effectivement quel
que soit le sentiment qu'on a à l'égard
de nicolas sarkozy je pense que c'est un
scandale
ce qui est dramatique dans ses affaires
quand ça touche des politiques c'est que
tous les gens je vais devoir les réseaux
sociaux actuellement tous les gens qui
n'aiment pas trop nicolas sarkozy se
réjouissent de manière ce qui n'est pas
mélenchon se réjouissent et ceux qui
n'aimaient pas le pen se réjouit c'est
ce qui n'est pas fillon se réjouit c'est
là mon avis tout le monde est perdant
tout cas la démocratie est perdante je
vous donne bien sûr la parole cher
mathieu mais je voudrais d'abord la
donner aux internautes si vous le voulez
bien on pose la question sur twitter
pensez vous que la demande de quatre ans
de prison qui sont contre nicolas
sarkozy relève d'un raid histoire
politique et bien c'est oui mais 58%
donc c'est relativement tôt
équilibré avec respect sur lefigaro.fr
nos dix jeux de combat bien si sarkozy
n'a rien à se reprocher pourquoi at il
usé et abusé de tous les recours
possibles pour ne pas passer devant la
justice va peut-être comme le disait
jérôme parce que le poids moral d'une
dune d'une poursuite pénale est
extrêmement lourd pour un responsable
politique
également parce que la base aussi aucune
fois que je pars faire la faire ici mais
la basse et des écoutes qui elle-même
pose problème on écoute des avocats sur
une autre affaire alors qu'il s'agit
quand même d'une ligne cachée d'une
ligne parallèle prise au nom de police
mettent en jeu martin sur youtube nous
dit qu'on va me laisser un parti
politique créé le parc national
financier s'est lui donné l'immunité
judiciaire le contrôle de l'opposition
et il ajoute la séparation des pouvoirs
est un mythe
depuis que hollande est passé et un
dernier mot que nous laissons à pattes
sur le figaro.fr qui regrette surtout
que mitterrand soit passé à côté du
tribunal des trucs sur 7 sur eux
cette sorte de deux prises de pouvoir un
peu par la fois par les juges qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
politique devient un métier très
complexe et jugé finalement un métier
aussi très complexe parce qu'on voit
bien que la justice est soumise à des
attentes extrêmement contradictoires de
la part de l'opinion
on veut de la transparence on veut du
contrôle démocratique on veut évidemment
que nos élus soient irréprochables
vierge de tout soupçon notamment en
matière de corruption et derrière on
voit bien que la gestion de tout ça est
complexe
la question c'est effectivement est ce
que le rôle que aujourd'hui les juges
prennent ce occupe constitue un
dévoiement de la démocratie ou un
approfondissement de la démocratie par
exemple il faut être à chaque fois
extrêmement nuit on sait par rapport à
ça quand il quand ils interviennent dans
la gestion de la crise sanitaire
en ouvrant des ddd enquête préliminaire
en dix ans alors il ya peut-être
homicide involontaire mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui c'est exactement ce que
j'allais dire les politiques sont pris
précisément en tenaille par des juges
mais de l'autre côté la crise sanitaire
et les exemples que vous que vous donnez
le révèle y compris les citoyens c'est à
dire que de plus en plus c'est que ce
sont des citoyens qui saisissent la
justice
en pleine crise en pleine catastrophe
pour vérifier la responsabilité de
responsables politiques dont convient
que la chose est complexe mais pour nous
on sait ce que disait jérôme en dépit du
pouvoir pris par les juges y compris
dans un dans un cadre électoral la
présidentielle
on voit bien que finalement l'opinion a
pas tellement bougé par rapport à ça à
françois fillon qui était effectivement
qui a été pendant des mois soumis à aa
une à une actualité judiciaire assez
rude à a fini dans le quarté de tête des
candidats en tant que fondeur j'ai quand
même bien suivi l'élection si vous
voulez que c'est le rôle bnf a été
absolument détermine que ça lui a fait
du tort je le conteste pas un préfet
tuteur à démocratie ça nous a privés du
débat démocratique pendant dix semaines
moi je ne compte plus d émissions ou au
lieu de parler du qu'on peut dire les
choses différemment chargé romsa à
éclairer le débat démocratique avec une
lui avec une autre lumière non avec une
autre lumière
je pense que beaucoup d'électeurs de
françois fillon qui leur est portée à la
présidence de la république et aurait
découvert après coup la sphère qu'on lui
reproche ce serait eux même senti trahi
je ne suis pas sûr que la démocratie en
ut grande hydraulique ont passé le cours
des députés n'ont pas le monde n'aurait
en tout cas jusqu'à présent et à la
présidence de la république merci
beaucoup à tous les deux pour ce débat
passionnant merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous demain pour un
nouvel épisode de points de vue très
bonne soirée
[Musique]